you know I have my ear I got your
whatever buds yes I do not hear what the
three of you were just laughing it was
opening and the three of you being Mike
Bell Tuco Chris Brockman and back here
on the Rich Eisen show Danica Danica
Patrick good to see you Danica is it is
it safe for work what you guys know it's
just like the baby shark thing I just I
can't I can't keep listening that it
drives me insane that's not how I want
to start my weekend right is having this
thing and grained in my brain so you're
fine with it during other weekdays it's
just the fact that it's the weekend let
it go and Danica Greece got on this
island alone do you agree with this one
nails down a chalkboard terrible I like
to surround myself with good positive
high vibe music right the baby shark is
not an acceptable is that what it's
called yeah yeah it is it's called baby
shark it is well that's just there you
go they sing about different sharks in
the family as well and it goes on so is
it an educational program it is
definitely not Chris I think your take
on it you're tryna you're trying to get
yourself a spot in the pretty intense
podcast so take right there just talk
about dumb music I'm there
Congrats on your pod here Thank You
Manica pretty intense podcast it dropped
the first episode as the kids like to
say yeah just yesterday yeah hey Ron
yeah was your first guest huh Alex
Rodriguez yes yes that a-rod there are
kind of two but I actually really don't
think of my a rod as a rod at all there
are some people that do call him a rod
that are like basically like I mean
friends forever right um like the Hawks
like Laura hockey played with a Jayhawk
for a long time and we're always causing
a rod but I don't I think of a rod Alex
Rodriguez as a rod I do too I I just I
don't think of Aaron as a rod no but so
Ali Iran double-a hey Ron a a Ron hey
Ron is one way that you could go
Canadian tuxedo
we can do that is very stylish I go to
him for advice and it's sure enough I'll
go out and do whatever I'm doing and
people are like oh you look really good
and I'm like mommy you know Aaron picked
it out so or he bought me this yes
that's in tuxedo what do we think of
this here this he he has a total sense
of humor
anyone that pays enough attention to him
realizes that I mean you just have to
look at the mustache to realize he has a
sense of humor and and so he loves Sam
Elliot so it's really an ode to Sam
Elliot sure and he you know you know I
think that you know the scruff is the
the the normal good look and then you
know the scruff kind of grows out and
then he's like wow I need to get rid of
this so let's just roll with the
mustache cuz that's doing so well now
right and then it's a mustache for a
while and then it'll be a clean shave
for about a day and a half until it
grows back out again and then it'll be
scruff over again so yeah this was uh I
mean they played in Winnipeg so this was
his this was his homage to Canada yeah
and he pulled the bolo out and I was
like oh what do you do he's like you
know good Canadian tuxedo and so I hoped
a little bit only I think my biggest
contribution was he had a Canada beanie
or cowboy hat and he said which one and
I said maybe you don't need either like
it's nice when you walk this fine line
of like looking a little to put together
for a costume that makes people confused
and that's right the line he likes to
walk like are you serious that's him I
mean if you know him very well his
comedy is like are you serious or even
his comments sometimes are like are you
serious and people don't know how to
take him and that's it looks really good
I would say that your your OneNote was
an excellent note and a key clearly took
that note because we there was no hay
yet he had the head the headsets on
though he said we'll just do a nice
comb-over I said that's it that's it do
that winner
so he's growing that mustache out like
how long I think it's pretty grown out
its impression so I was like whoa babe
and he was like he's like what I'm like
yeah she's just looking strong he's like
what do you really mean I'm like a
little rough
[Laughter]
he's I mean he's adorable either way but
he just has a sense of humor so he can
keep the mustache offseason no I don't
care that would take me at least a month
to grow out looking that very Sam
Elliott like it really really would
that's impressive no I mean you can get
the scruff going in a day and a half
easily but but I think that that
mustache probably takes you know it
takes a couple of weeks of like letting
it go it also it comes probably from the
heart too right I mean you got to have
that heart Sam Elliott even attached him
official Sam Elliott doors I'm Sam if
you're watching he really likes you I
know let's have dinner or appear on the
pretty intense podcast right that would
be great and then I'll just have food
ready and it'll turn into a four hour
there we go there you go so what do you
talk about with Alex Rodriguez what's
the conversation about um well I mean
the conversation with Alex was I kind of
worked a little backwards in time from
him from like where he is now - you know
more of his youth but we talked a lot
about what he's really interested other
than baseball which is numbers and
investments and he's been investing
since he got into baseball once since he
since he was you know 20 years old so
he's just a real numbers guy and I'm
intrigued by that because I'm not a
numbers girl like I've brain melt down
as soon as people start to do 1 + 3 yeah
more verbal than math yeah verbal yeah I
don't do math at all now math is not for
me either so it's really interesting and
also just that mindset of accomplishing
something else and other interests that
you have and you know we're not
one-dimensional people we have outside
interests other than just what you see
us doing right but then of course the
the route of the show is to talk about
growth a growth mindset and how to you
know the human elements of the stories
but then as as a means to an ends of
understanding how somebody grew from it
so it's like okay you know yes your
performance enhancing situation and
being suspended and
I don't really want to talk about that
what I want to talk about is what came
from that like where did you go as a
human to deal with that and what were
your coping skills and what does the
what does it look like to be in the dirt
you know like it's okay to say how bad
it looked for a second because it's
relatable and so the show is meant to
create a safe place to be a little bit
vulnerable to not really talk about the
bad bad but really talk about how it
became good well I mean it's in Danica
Patrick here in the Rich Eisen show
check out weekly podcast a pretty
intense we're all podcasts can be
downloaded with Alex I mean that's a
crucial part of of what's going on with
him what went on with him because he was
I mean the only way to put it with off
the reservation in terms of baseball in
terms of just accusing baseball of
certain things that sounded wild to say
the least and then all of a sudden just
turned it's a page turned right and a
light went on I don't know what happened
well it's accountability so as soon as
you start taking accountability for
yourself you have to be vulnerable
because you're admitting faults as soon
as you do that you realize that there's
more strength than the vulnerability
than there was in the hiding of it that
it seems seems weak to be vulnerable but
it's really strong to have that amount
of confidence and courage to do it
well in terms of strength and in terms
of being a woman doing something for the
first time for you to have Gloria
Steinem on that's gonna have to have you
recorded that one already yes I did yeah
this little sneak preview what she was
like frustratingly refreshingly simple
that's how I would describe it because
you you you know I wanted to talk about
these feminism issues and like you know
cultural issues and even just you know
the dynamics of like polarity in life
and duality and and she's like it's not
real it's not real and she just got to a
very very simple place of you know we're
here to experience life right here right
now this is what's happening and so it
was really like almost too simple and I
think we do try and complicate things
humans on every level and in every way
we try and complicate things and it's so
much more simple than that and that's
what you end up getting from people
especially that are older that have more
experience and perspective is this
simplistic approach to things but you
know it's almost like we get addicted to
the drama of complication and it's not
it doesn't need to be like that so who
do you want to have on your show mom
will you do it sure okay of course thank
you I love doing home in homes spot you
want to tape your podcast I love doing
them back and forth let's do it done
that quite a few times now I'll tell you
the secret to my success I'd love to
hear that
please I'm like I've done 35 episodes
and you've done how many years this
we're coming up on our fifth anniversary
yeah and you know it's also interesting
the other thing that we share too is
hosting you hosted the ESPYs you hosted
the ESPYs I've never hosted in ESPYs
reason why I'm bringing this up I'm
gonna go there again what does that mean
have a host oh yeah now the Emmys have
followed suit and I'm pissed about it is
you want you shot well I'm not just I
want my shot I just like hosts are not
disposable
we are crucially important individuals
for shows your television and/or charity
projects we must be a crucial component
and I don't like where this is going
Danika you know what I'm saying
so you hosted the ESPYs yeah and that's
a crucial role like fantastic experience
exactly they could have an ESPYs without
a host they could have a rod come out
with LeBron or you know and comes out
with Drew Brees and and and and a voice
of God as we say comes down and says
ladies and gentlemen to the stage you
they come no but there are more
opportunities than ever to become your
own host I mean look at me
know I have any past history of that
I've never asked anyone questions before
and Here I am sitting down with Gloria
Steinem for over an hour you're asking
questions so there's more opportunities
than ever though to be a host in that
regard I'm talking about award show
you want an award show my daddy whether
you keep bringing it up like that's the
kind of the undercurrent here's me and
let's just bring it on full circle with
today's show with Alex Honnold being
here it's a slippery slope it's a
slippery slope when you grab on to the
rock that is a host and you don't have
that rock there you slip what are you
gonna bring to a show as a host that is
of value okay here's what I would bring
to those show hard-hitting I mean
question great question great question
here's what I would bring I would bring
a fun what's the word floor there's a
letter D and then there's a letter D and
then there's - bag okay okay free okay
that person hey you what you will be
able to enjoy all two three hours if
there is an issue I will come out and
defuse the situation if there is the
wrong winner announced I will come out
and fix it okay how is this exclusive
just to you it's my own my own style
I've asked the question what does what
makes my podcast different than another
ones especially in this emerging
conscience consciousness world of like
you know shows that are talking about
growing and expanding or open-mindedness
and growth mindset and self-care and you
know what makes my show different right
and so I just asked that question to
myself a few days ago right and I'm like
me right I mean I make it different if
you like the way that I run the show the
line of questioning the vein of thinking
if you like my stories cuz it's an
inevitable that you're gonna get my
stories along the way so that's what you
have to like about it if you're like
that's why the you know what's the name
of this show Mike tell 2-fold remind
everybody with the name of the show is
over there I mean
that was a good one no and then he just
takes forever dies this is the Rich
Eisen show so if you if you if you kind
of don't like me first of all what the
hell's the matter with you but secondly
uh three hours with me you know you
might have a trouble but if not let's
all hang out so I have my own unique
footprint and fingerprint and on top of
it for an award show I'm kind of like
the fan being a sports Danica my espy
invitation has been lost since 2003 when
did you see my rap skin of how I
supposedly got the gig yes by the way
the writing staff is extremely talented
more Ament and I go way way back
I love Morra it took 15 to 18 writers to
get me that funny many you know I know
well you were great at it I'm just
trying to bring up again that hosts are
people too that's all I'm saying
hashtag hashtag so who would you want
yeah I know you asked me which was very
kind of you who would you want to have
on the show like what's the Danica
Patrick wish list here I mean I think
that uh Oprah I mean seriously don't you
yes there's a limit myself in my dreams
and aspirations I'd like to get more
than 35 shows under my belt before I
interview Oprah but but I I I would love
that because I feel like she was a large
part of what got me interested in you
know investigating into people right and
understanding more about their story and
how it can help us right and so super
soul Sunday was a show that I watched
many times whenever I had time and I
wasn't driving right which hopefully the
race was late enough I could catch it so
super soul Sunday was always was
something that was very helpful in that
transition I also think somebody like a
Brene brown would be amazing super great
storyteller as well as like a scientist
of human nature and emotions Russell
Brand would be really cool
Rochelle Rogan
okay yeah I mean there's there's a
there's a there's a long list of really
amazing and you know what's great and
maybe you get this on the show too sure
is that sometimes someone that you don't
see coming turns out to blow you away
true right you're like wow I don't I
didn't know anything about them or I had
a different opinion of them and then you
sit down and talk to them for a little
while and you are taken back and so I
also love the the element of surprise
and that's happened many times with the
shows well it is it is a joy to be part
of something like that and you should
take if you get that sort of feeling you
should take pride in the fact that you
felt that way because you if you felt
that way and it's genuine than anybody
who's listening is gonna feel that way
too and I I love the fact in all honesty
whenever I interview and whether it was
on the NFL Network for many years or on
this show somebody saying you know I
hated that guy
because I root against him or I hated
that person because I root against them
now I'm gonna be a fan cuz you find out
they're a human being who bleeds who's
got a life
who's got family real people that's true
for the world no matter where you go or
what you do people are inherently pretty
good you think she's some bad apples but
when you get down to the root of it
anything that is projected that doesn't
feel good is an insecurity
or a trauma that's inside of them that
they're that they're projecting they're
putting on a brisk o armor to protect
themselves but at the root of it when
you can get down to the level of
vulnerability they're good well
check out the new podcast it launched
yesterday Alex Rodriguez and chef Marcus
Samuelsson yeah next week is Neil
deGrasse Tyson so now if you want to
talk about it look really wide wide
range so far people actually to athletes
only so far more as a rod and and Tony
Kanaan Tony Kanaan
yes well there we go yeah Alex Rodriguez
in the Neil deGrasse Tyson though I mean
you can't get it I mean that that will
call those bookends thank you right
that's you run you're running the gamut
to say the least
thanks for coming on you were welcome
here anytime as you know that yeah and
and if you really do want me on your
part
you're not just saying that I'm not just
saying that absolutely all right so
we're gonna get 52 shows to book a year
so I need peace by the way uh you know
what
that's when you're gonna do a podcast
called warm bodies then I'll come on
what an invitation well I got a book the
show out sure I'm sure we'll have a good
conversation that was my attempt at
humor which is why I'm doing the show
like that it's a podcast
Danika serious podcast pretty intense
ones pretty intense check it all out
everyone on twitter at pretty intense
and then an instagram at pretty intense
by danika it really was born from the
book because the book is called pretty
intense but it's a good descriptor you
know what it's called a brand you're
expanding the brand and and I would be
more than happy to be part you got it
just let me know when somebody drops out
I'll be there
ah Danica Patrick on Twitter and
Instagram right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app